this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday
the 15th of august 36 years since i got
sentenced to the biggie the pokey anyway
the joint is brought to you by liquid iv
listen it's been really hot lately and
i've been staying hydrated you know how
with some liquid iv you got to remember
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water will hydrate you two times faster
than just water alone i love liquid iv
my favorite flavor is concord grape
the uh
the berry from uh not guava guava berry
or something it's called i like tropical
punch and they also have a kombucha that
is smoking jack listen you could use
liquid iv like me first thing in the
morning
you feel run down you're just waking up
after a long night and you can manage
daily hydration like i said the single
serving packaging helps you keep stay
hydrated while on the go listen i use it
in the morning guys i put a little uh
oxygen in there
i get my little uh grape flavor or my
little
guava berry and forget about it liquid
iv contains five essential vitamins b3
b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c and it contains
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sport drinks that made with
premium liquid iv is free from gluten
dairy and soy listen let's cut this [__]
liquid iv is tremendous it tastes great
and it goes down smooth they got a
kombucha
that is tremendous you just put it in
the bottled water or in your little
liquid iv container there and shake it
up and you'll be brand new within
minutes grab your liquid ip today in
bulk from costco
or i'm going to save you 15
when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code joey to check out again that's 15
of anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
joey at liquidity.com
that's liquid iv.com called joey taste
that concord grape it's gonna make your
eyeball pop out the joint is also
brought to you by my favorite draftkings
listen this saturday ufc 278 has an
action-packed card throw down and grab
your epic victory with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
part of the ufc what i'm going to do
this saturday is this new customers you
can bet five dollars and get 203 bets
instantly win or lose you can play
football college football coming up and
if that's not enough action you could
also combine
usman with uh like paul acosta and get a
same day parlay ten bucks is risk-free
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will come up on top
and how long the fight will last
ba-boom they got it all props the whole
thing but it starts this saturday with
ufc 278 that's ko joey this saturday on
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc and
hey here's what the part the lawyers
make me say
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply
see my show notes for details now
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's get ready to make some money
or download the draftkings fantasy app
and get ready for football season it's
going to be big they got a million
dollars in prizes they're giving away
light that candle let's get this [__]
podcast started [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 15th of the [__]
month it's the halfway point
i hope everybody's doing well was a
great [__] weekend it's been a great
couple of uh weeks we haven't had a chat
a chat a time to chit chat about what's
been going on but everything's [__]
great
uh i'm happy you enjoyed the eric rocha
podcast
when we covered gay pride in june i know
it was a month too late but [__]
things happen
uh lee was great it was really really
great to see lee i'm happy you guys
always get a kick out of him coming on
the podcast uh
he's a [__] different dude man he's a
different dude and you know what we all
are
i can sit here with mike and i'm a
different dude you know what we all are
different it's it's
uh sitting next to him here we i mean
there's tons of love when he came down
we went to eat one night we [__] uh
we just did silly [__] one thing one
night for dinner we just went to carvel
like we just went to carvel you know
what i'm saying no bridge that's my
favorite car bell they got a
[__] drive-through we didn't go
through the drive-through because you
know
but we sat outside we just watched the
[__] people and we were like making
bets on who's got diabetes who's gonna
get diabetes it's funny when you stand
in front of an ice cream joint or a
candy joint or something like that i'm
not making fun of people with diabetes
but jesus christ
you know listen i get my blood checked
four times a year and i look for two
things cholesterol and my sugar that's
the more i don't care about my
testosterone i knocked her up [__] it
it's done i don't even need testosterone
and you can see my hair is standing
through the [__] i don't even need
the head cuts no more i'm at an age
where my head cuts itself you know what
i'm saying
you don't know how lucky you are like
these mother factors tap out and shave
their head i can never shave my head
because if you think i'm i'm ugly now
[__] forget about it scars
god knows what's in my head but it's so
funny how i'm getting so old i don't
even need haircuts no more the [__]
hairdo's thinning out my wife says to me
do you want to do something about it i
go what i want to do about
what do i do about it the hair was here
when i needed it it's time to move on
you know what i'm saying
it's time to move on from the hair i got
a kid i already got a wife i had two
wives i slung some dick you know that's
it i my hair served its [__] purpose
you know what i'm saying you cut you
cover it a different way and it all
works out it tricks people you know
people thought i had a lot of hair but
now i'm down to [__] nothing and
that's the way it is i'm not sweating it
i had i had a friend
he's still my friend we haven't spoken
in like six years but i guarantee he's
still [__] hitting himself every day
with a treatment
i remember when he was putting lemons on
his bald head i mean this guy went
through [__] hell with that i used to
tell him you're a beautiful [__] dude
who gives a [__] about hair you need
hair to get [__] you know
he's still not married so i guess he was
right you know
yeah no everybody got a [__] hair
transplant you know everybody thought
that's what it was but it just
those things don't keep you know i'm
saying that little squirrel's nest
don't keep but i don't want to talk
about [__] people's hairdos and wigs
and [__] like that i was watching a
movie the other night with one of the
best movies i've ever seen it's uh
they've been playing it a lot
like uh
on showtime i think the cinemax has
called nothing in common
[__] jackie gleason and tom hanks tom
hanks plays his son
and his mom is great i forget who the
actress plays his mom but hector
lozando's in the movie
and hector plays his [__] uh boss and
hector
has a wig and every time he sees tom
hanks he goes hey man
how does it look can you tell you know
all this [__]
and he's really insecure about his wig
so there's one scene where he goes to
check on tom hanks
and [__] tom hanks his mother's there
with him and she's checking out the wig
from the side and tom's trying to
[__]
get enough to check out the wig and also
he walks away the mom goes that's the
worst [__] wig i've ever seen in my
life my mom don't say that to him i
don't even know how he got to this point
about wigs i just i i just always felt
uncomfortable
about a guy who had to wear a wig
because he felt uncomfortable that's the
weirdest [__] thing last night i went
to a saturday night i went to a little
bash a birthday party
and on the way out i was talking to a
guy about knee surgeries whatever when
we were waiting for the car to come
and he had a tremendous wig he had the
one that you just put over the whole
thing
like like john uh what's his name uh joe
patliano and [__] uh the sopranos
when he pulled his hair out and the
[__] head was like the wig it was
like the
the hooker we mugged and [__] 82 we
pulled the head and the wig came off
but uh
[__]
yeah it's been a great [__] week i
mean lee
he's back in boston you know he went to
philly for a couple days teamed up with
steve stimone they went over to angelo's
a shout out to angelo's that [__]
pizza is tremendous the red pie is
[__] tremendous they said they had
some sandwiches and a bunch of [__] so
he got the love from philadelphia
and uh he's back in boston he was gonna
stop by yes i was gonna take him to the
[__] uh pickled herring uh because he
was gonna stop by here on sunday at
about 11
and then pick up a bunch of pastrami and
some other jewish delicacies and then he
was going to shoot up to his mother eat
jewish food with a and he's taken a he
took it to the boston red sox game last
night
in uh fenway against the [__] yankees
so listen man he's happy i wish him all
up in the world and you heard it here
first
i always [__] knew it i knew he was
gonna get it together
the only [__] up thing he did here was
he ate mcdonald's one night burger king
i almost stabbed him all that [__]
weight and all that when you eat burger
king now you got to walk back to the
moon and back
so a little liquid iv i don't know what
my canteen is my wife took it
oh there it is but it's [__] dirty
yeah we'll wash it later so it's 16
ounces of water it's this simple guys
you just pop this [__] in here
and sometimes i put a little [__]
cell food in this [__] a little
oxygen oh lordy
you eat some garlic pills and a little
oxygen what comes out of your ass is
tremendous you understand me
sorry about the squeeze and i know i'll
get some [__] but anyway
let's talk about some stand-up comedy
and something that happened thursday
night i don't know if
a lot of you guys don't know what
happened thursday night was one of my
best shows ever not me personally like
my materials suck dick
but i'll tell you what was great about
this show this was the last
i've done uh
six shows and uncle vinnie's i just and
then i go all the other places i drop in
here drop in there
i like uncle vinnie's small
i feel comfortable there lee and i both
said it reminds you of stage two
in uh pasadena [__] nice room i mean
i don't even know when the ice house is
opening up again but i've seen pictures
and it looks [__] beautiful
but this uncle venice has just been a
listen guys this seat's 150 160
it's no glamour you know the food is
[__] great you know i i didn't know
how to feel about it at first but now i
feel great about it byob
that's the best [__] thing i've ever
you know you bring what you [__]
drink people are there with coolers it's
just tremendous i really enjoy the place
dino is [__] aces
i'll perform there till i [__] die i
love the goddamn place but let me tell
you what happened wednesday night
i didn't tell you guys i told the
patreon people
so wednesday
lee was here ari came
ari was here for the day we went over to
the [__] uh chinese place and he got
his general tiles chicken
ari came jimmy came over all hanging out
talking [__]
when they left when they left around two
o'clock ari hung out and i got a call
from a buddy of mine in vegas mario
arias
and he goes hey man i'm just giving you
a heads up
mr libido is showing up to your show
tonight
mr lovito was our sixth grade teacher at
mckinley school in north bergen cool
[__]
so
i'm like really miss libido's coming i
spoke to miss libido when i first moved
back here
mario gave me his number we had a great
conversation and
he lives close by he was a couple
minutes from point pleasant so
or close to lbi i'm sorry so
i haven't seen mr libido since 1982.
so i'm up on stage i had
you know i put a couple things together
i put a bit together believe it or not
i finally put like a little little bit
there's a little run there's like two
little runs one run
is more for fan like a family type show
i can't be doing that material about
savages because they'll go joy we don't
want to hear about your daughter and
then the other one is what i'm about
what's going on in my life right now you
know
and uh
i was about to go into it but i knew mr
lovito was in the audience so i'm like
you know what
i was about 10 minutes and i got to
address this dude i go listen before i
go any further i had a i heard a rumor
that my sixth grade teacher was coming
tonight mr levito and i looked and he
raised his hand
and the place [__] clap for him the
place went nuts and then
what i wanted to do is use him as a
sound board you know for years people
like joey these stories couldn't have
happened some of my best stories
happened at [__] mckinley so many
things happened i remember a lot of them
like they had to remind me about a lot
of this [__] after the show we went to
the green room we were talking [__]
but uh
you know i thanked him because the story
with levito why he's so important in
this whole thing and he's in the book is
because in the sixth grade when i first
got to i was i lived in north bergen
since 73
but i went to like catholic school i got
thrown out and then i went to mckinley
when i my first day at mckinley my
mother had a friend that was uh his name
was
adam what the [__] was his name pepe go
that means uh
he's got like a bum leg like he had like
a little platform foot
pepe coho was a drug dealer that was
also doubling as a roofing company guy
and one day the roof fell on him
in miami so he got a bunch of [__]
doe from a settlement so he didn't want
to sell coke no more or be a roofer so
he started a [__] clothing line right
like in 1975 or some [__]
and it was called canti veloce c-o-n-t
with a slash balachi like the velocity
papers with charles bronson
so right away my dick got hard my mother
said listen he sent you some shirts
put these shirts on they're really nice
shirts wore them to school i put one of
the shirts on without really looking at
it and it was a [__] greek orgy scene
like my first day in sixth grade i
walked into school and i didn't know it
to the kids like what is that is that a
[__] i had like women with hairy
[__] eating like grapes and [__] and
i remember at the end of the day mr
lovito's like i like the shirt i go you
know i'm sorry i [__] wore it
i didn't know what was on here and he's
like okay just don't worry again because
obviously you got the kids riled up but
that was my relationship mr libido on
the first day but he soon noticed he
goes this motherfucker's too hyper so he
cut me a deal because i tell you what
i'm gonna do and you've all heard this
deal before because teachers have been
doing it for years they go listen
if you behave all week i'll let you go
up on stage i'll let you go up in the
front of the class on mondays on fridays
at one o'clock
because we had a choice then we could
either be a part of the ecology club
where you went to a park and picked up
papers papa don't pick up no papers even
then in the sixth grade right
and uh
or
you could sit in class
or go to catechism
i think i got thrown out of catechism
like two months in because one of the
kids asked the [__] priest
how do they know the bible [__] was for
real anybody could have wrote that it's
a mickey mouse book oh my god get the
[__] out the whole thing so my options
now with the ecology club or to sit with
these [__] jamoks
in this class but i figured the jamoks
that sat down with a lot of girls it was
more girls than guys so
one day lavito goes go ahead do what you
need to do up there you did well so i
brought a a
record player to school well they had a
record player and i put on frankie
valley and i would go up there every
friday and sing my eyes at georgia in
the sixth grade i thought it was a
[__] crooner right like i thought it
was like sinatra
but i was too ugly so the girls wouldn't
listen to me sing i would walk over to
him like with the [__] make-believe i
had a microphone my eyes are george and
they go go away
just go away it was so embarrassing so i
figured my singing wasn't any good so i
started cracking jokes
and since the only [__] comic i
really liked was the sixth grade was
richard pryor i would basically go up
there every friday and do [__] the
one album i showed you
uh is this something i said and
bicentennial whatever i would bring all
those i would go down there and [__]
do the thing verbatim
and he would just shake his head like he
can't [__] do this [__] you know but
that's the story those are probably the
inner roots of stand up for me
so i always thank them i always thank
them in little things whenever i talk to
people they said they speak to lovito i
would always go thank mr levito for
putting me on stage you know so
everything was going great we're just up
there telling stories about how we were
going to kill the gym teacher
you know how [__] and mr vito was
loving this [__] he's like after he's
like coco
you have a memory he goes i didn't
remember half this [__]
you know telling stories about how we
used to rob shoprite as a kid and then
go back and throw hubba bub at each
other who throws hubba bubba at each
other nobody
but the highlight of the night
we were just getting into karma and
balzano and how he beat up mr tatora i
mean this [__] was all happening right
in front of us in grammar school we
spoke about my friend anthony balzano
when he died how [__] sad it was
how his parents went on the news channel
4 news before [__]
saturday night live it was just a a
great time but the highlight of the
night i go
mr lovito tell these [__] what
happened
when they put a hit of acid and mr
aggressed his coffee
he used to have a thermos like that
[__] liquid iv thing and he would put
on his desk and all day drink coffee
from it while he was talking to the
students and teaching
one of the kids
took his when he stepped out to get like
i don't know supplies they took his
coffee it was hot and they put a hit a
bladder acid in it
and after lunch this [__]
teacher didn't come back in fact he
didn't come back like two days
he couldn't have figured out what
happened to him he told me the story
afterwards so i go do you remember when
they put a acid in mr agreste's coffee
and he goes yeah he's right there
he was at the show so he's like i do
remember that and i go hey mr gresta how
you doing i really
i had already stuck my foot in my mouth
i'm like hey mr grassland how how are
you doing
he goes good coco like a listen for the
record it wasn't me but i'm not a crime
stop and then the mystery it was eddie
lamenka and lamenka was a crazy cuban
kid that moved to florida fast as [__]
this guy was a born thief he could run
he could jump fences a tremendous
so afterward he came back and he goes i
can't believe they put an ass in my
thing he goes i heard about it years
later that it was acid he goes i could
have killed me but he also reminded me
about something else he goes the last
time i saw you you came up to me and
asked me if i could fake you fix you up
with my niece patty emerson i'm like
holy [__]
patty emerson was a girl that was a
sweetheart dear
just a dear friend of mine
and she was so sweet i like this so much
i'm like you know what i can't hit on
this girl
she's just gonna be my friend
and then we started calling to patty nat
because at parties people would see it
and go you know what i want to take her
from a date and then
i'm like she's too sweet for you man
but every guy would always go oh my god
look how hot she is maybe i'll go talk
to patty and then they go nah so her
name ended up being patti nan
we would just call her patty matt
because nobody was allowed to talk to
her or to touch her and i told this on
the church it got so bad with patty nat
that i remember when she went to her
first year at college she came to joe
and mary and she's like listen guys
you got to stop [__] protecting me i
can't get no guys to hit on me because
they know that if somebody hits on me
you guys because one of my friends
pissed on a guy that was making out with
us so
it was just [__] uh
she i go that's your [__] niece and
he's like yeah she's doing great she
lives in long island you'll send them my
love i haven't seen him in [__] years
but guys
it was just great to see
one of you it inspired me so much over
the weekend i called like two other ones
of my teachers i'm like listen i'm doing
a show in the city
and i'd like for you guys to come i'll
send the car for you an uber whatever i
have one of my friends come pick you up
you know i got mr barone
mr terranova's mad at me because last
week he was down the shore and he wanted
for me to go see him but we already had
plans he dropped it on me the day before
so i couldn't oh it was the day lee was
coming
so i was waiting on late to come he was
like i'm having a party at 12 i'm like
dog i don't know what time i get over
there
because my friend's coming i don't want
to rush over to the house and then him
hit me in half [__] in the stride and i
got to come back
so i ended up not going i called him
like wednesday didn't pick up the phone
that means he's mad at me for a few days
it [__] happens but the fact that
i tell you guys i was a tyrant i was a
[__] nightman all this [__] and i
still communicate
with my [__] teachers
is it's just uh
it makes me proud it really does man i
felt so great after that show the other
night you know and that's why i'd love
to do a show like that
just get one of my teachers
like before the book i was thinking
about this
getting like a teacher or an ex-coach
or friends of mine that wouldn't mind
being on camera
or not camera
wouldn't mind me bouncing off them like
tell these [__] about the time
we mugged the dude in jersey city just
any
i don't know i'm not saying i'm not
gonna do it in jersey i'm just saying
you know it would be great to just
confirm these stories you know what i'm
saying like just [__] have a good
time because they're all 30 40 years ago
nobody gives a [__]
you know nobody cares i can't believe
i told the story on rogan
about this girl lori jack when we were
growing up
when we were growing up
when we were growing up right i just
told the story on rogue and maybe what
five years ago six years ago
the other day one of my [__] high
school buddies who i talked to a lot
said to me uh
he called we were talking about
something he goes hey man
you told me you did it but i didn't
believe you and he goes but i saw it the
other day he goes do you know that the
lorry jack story
has like 15 million downloads combined
because i think joe rogan has it
somebody else had and then people copied
it
he's got a couple of clips
yeah i didn't i don't check on those
things i don't know what's up there
he's like it's got like 15 minutes he
goes have you ever heard from her has
she ever said anything to you and i go i
see her on facebook all the time
she might not see you though huh
no no no we're friends on facebook she
she hit me up one day you want to be
friends with me
that was a long time ago and you know uh
[Music]
i mean she's never said nothing tell me
15 million
he told me
no she's around you know i see a post on
there who the [__] knows man i i'm just
trying to [__] have a good time here
you know i'm just trying to
that's it this is what i've been doing
lately man i'm just it's a different
[__] world
and lee
helped me confirm that the other day
lee really helped me confirm a lot of
[__] about me this week
on things i want to do things i used to
do things i didn't want to do you know
it's uh
one thing i'm really happy about guys
it did get really out of control
it really did it really [__] did and
and
you know you cannot eat 2 000 milligrams
of abx daily
there's gonna be a [__] you know we
pay for everything i vote i've said this
for years no matter what you do in this
life you pay for it might not be today
and it might not be tomorrow but
somewhere along the line it's gonna pop
up to [__] bite you in the ass and
not in a bad way
just it might affect your health
something you did years earlier you know
and it's uh
i'm happy to be
i i can't say i'm sober
because i'm really not i smoked before
the show this morning i smoked before i
went to the gym you know
but it's not even i'm embarrassed to say
this sometimes it's not even
one thing i am doing is getting super
high on wheat
like i have to honest be honest with
everybody like i am getting so high on
weed now
it's scary
like it's back to the point where i sm
if i smoke a joint
i'm going to sleep
after i eat a half a box of special okay
some blueberries some cantalopes this is
what i do every [__] night i mean you
know
i get so high in the daytime that i'm
okay
and i'm happy i hate to [__] say this
but i'm kind of happy to be this sober
right now
like i
guys
i gotta tell you man the last two years
you know to see
everything moving and for you to step to
the back has been
it's been a [__] great experience
because i didn't know
i had no [__] idea
what was going on was going on i really
didn't it was just
you know people like i can't believe you
don't want to do this anymore do you
understand why i just stepped out of it
was just
total anxiety like i tell you guys a
podcast was six hours
we didn't do it now we did an hour and a
half but we were there six [__] hours
so mike would be getting here like
monday at 12 he wouldn't leave till six
what do you tell your wife
yeah like everybody wanted to leave for
six [__] hours when you're married
but i'm home
i'm home i got nowhere you know what i'm
saying so
it just took so [__] much but right
now what i'm looking at lately i just
been looking at this
and i tell my wife once a [__] month
i tell my wife i tell mike i tell lee i
tell my friends i go never mind the
house
never mind the book
never mind losing weight never mind
having a child never mind any of this
[__]
one of the things i wake up every
morning and i [__] dog i do gratitude
[__] every [__] morning you know i
told my wife i used to get up in the
morning get a cup of coffee from the
kitchen and go right in front of the
computer that is horrible for you
i'm telling you this right now guys it's
[__] horrible for you
when you wake up in the morning you know
throughout the night you went into rem
sleep or whatever and you've processed
it it's not just your muscles
and your heart everything gets a [__]
charge up you wake up at three in the
morning to pee and you tap into a dream
what's going what's your mind going
while you're sleeping like sometimes
you i wake up to pee and i'm thinking
about the weirdest thought because it
was probably what i was dreaming about
before but your mental is dreaming like
your mental is resting everything is
resting so when you wake up your brand
[__] new again
you're brand new again like whatever
problems you had that were really
affecting you you've broken down now you
slept that's why people always say let
me sleep on it let me [__] sleep on
it okay
so when you wake up in the [__]
morning if you wake up refreshed and
there's not like for me i never woke up
refreshed i'm not gonna lie to you
people i walked up and as i was pissing
i'm still [__] high from last night
you know my heart's beating i'm thinking
about the gig i don't wanna [__] do
tonight and then never mind that i gotta
do something else and then tomorrow i
gotta get on a plane at 4 30 in the
morning
guys this is what you wake up with now
you sit in front of the [__] computer
and you open up twitter or facebook and
it's like you know it's just a [__]
grind you know like it's just or you
open up yahoo or [__]
whatever cnn and it it just takes you
for a [__] ride and i didn't know how
bad it was affecting me i remember i
would get on the phone i would get up at
seven
and by 7 30 people talking to me about
business in new york and i'm like
that's not good
i guess i did it for years it works when
you're [__] you know
but somewhere around there i like to get
up now
like if i get up at 7 30
i grab a cup of coffee and i go right
outside
i don't care if it's raining
i don't care if it's 30 below
i dress accordingly
and i go on my balcony under that
[__] umbrella and i just sit there
and i do my gratitude checks i say them
a little you know i speak them out so
the universe can hear me i'm grateful
for my house i'm grateful for having
friends like mike i'm grateful to wake
up this morning i'm grateful that my
dick still works i'm grateful that my
hair is cutting itself i don't have to
spend 50 bucks every two [__] months
you know you just do this gratitude
thing you know and
the gratitude the biggest gratitude i
have is i don't get high anymore
that cocaine [__]
and the [__] xanax [__] that i was
using for anxiety
that
without knowing it affects you no matter
what you take i know for a fact when i
had the knee surgery those pain pills
were [__] me up on a different level
i know for a [__] fact
that i did not feel good but what i've
noticed lately is i could tell now
for the first time in my [__] whole
life because i'm i don't look at that
thing i don't look at that
but for the first time i can tell when
somebody's doing drugs
yeah like i could tell now through their
language i had an idea i can't lie to
you no even if i don't see them
just from what they're writing
their topic what's on it's so stupid and
i'm not judging nobody i'm not judging
nobody i did drugs for 50 [__] years
who am i going to judge
yeah who am i going to [__] judge but
what i'm trying to say to you is
i could see
how it [__] affects you now
and i have three people
in my life right now that i talk to from
time to time
and it's so weird that i finally put
together
why they're so weird to me
on the phone
because they're getting high
don't understand that gibberish anymore
it's like comedy gibberish from l.a when
somebody from l.a calls me oh my god we
miss you so much it's like listen i
gotta go
my daughter's on the field she's about
to bat you want to call me with
gibberish that you miss me or whatever
the [__] they're telling you but
i can hear the drugs now guys i never
believe that if you listen to every
podcast i talked about
i said that all my failures over those
years
was on me i never blame nothing on drugs
i gotta taste them for the [__] first
time
in my life i'm blaming [__] on drugs
that i did
i can't believe this
i saw a [__] video
some [__] jerk off put it up
from la
and there was a time in that video that
was when i was getting high
and i saw that video and i listened to
what i was saying
and it was [__] disturbing
it was very disturbing on what
i was talking about in those days when i
was doing coke i now every time i think
about a conversation i [__] cringe
you ever think about a conversation you
have like in the sixth grade with a girl
when you went to hit on her and she's
like no but i'm flattered or whatever
the [__] they would say to you as a nice
way of saying you know you're a [__]
loser you know i still dread a
conversation i had with this girl named
davis rodriguez
in the sixth grade that it was the most
awkward conversation and i went up to
her and i asked her for a date and she's
like oh my god i'm in such shock but i
got to be honest to you
i don't see you that way but i'm flat
i'll never forget the word flatted
because i had to go home and look it up
she's like i'm flattered
that you thought of me for this dance
but
i uh already have somebody in mind
you know i still remember those
conversations when i sit here and tell
you guys that
i still remember my bombing and [__]
new orleans
yeah
you remember all those things i do
i definitely [__] do when i think
about the [__] i was talking about till
four in the morning with people when
you're doing coke oh god
that's the worst gibberish in the
[__] world anybody who's done coke
and has been with three people doing
coke at four in the morning i love you
oh my god i think the same it's like
when i watch boogie nights i [__]
love boogie nights
but when she's talking to marky warburg
and the other chick and they're saying i
love you i love you you're my mom you
know i thought i'm not gonna say i
didn't use that terminology i was the
king of that lingo i snorted a lot of
coke that's why after a while i could
smell coke with nobody i'm like i don't
want to smoke with nobody because i they
gotta hear my lingo and i gotta hear
what's coming out of that [__] spout
not today
the last four years five years i did
coke i was so low jack that's more
reasons listen i went to the [__]
uh breathing doctor friday okay
and they did an evaluation and then they
send you the report
and then she called me and she goes i
tell you why you've been getting dizzy
in your car
i'll tell you bro she broke it down for
me last week this [__] i forgot to
bring this up to you guys
she's like i don't know if they did
everything guys they test my lungs i was
there for three [__] hours last week
they tested lungs capacity
holding your breath under water i mean
guys they did everything
then they drive me up and they gave me a
neural exam
and the lady is like listen your ears it
is it's the ears of a 60 year old you
know whether you ruin them in concerts
or whatever the [__] you're blaming it
on
that's great but she goes i'm going to
talk to you about something
she goes you're here everything
that is wrong with you it's because of
your left [__] eye
because i don't know what happened to
your left eye i mean you ever see my
left eye goes that way
i was from doing too much coke on the
left side like you do one too many bumps
on the left side because i swear to god
my right nose
used to be the money nose right when you
first start doing coke it's the right
side you do oh that's not bad i like i
like to drip when you do the [__] but
then the nose on this side you know i
started in this nose in like 79 so by
the time 87 came i you know i was
breaking down to this left side and dawg
i know the knights when i would do a
line and i would feel my eye just go
and go that way and then i'd have to
[__] hit it
and then focus back in on the mirror and
i'm not telling nobody about this sham
i'm telling you people not because it
was 20 years ago i care about my eyes 20
years ago but i would [__] snort coke
toys i would do so much [__] coke
that i could feel my eye like [__]
trembling whatever the [__] it was now
when i was a kid i knew my eyes weren't
goofy because i had 20 20 [__] vision
so she said what happened did you have a
traumatic experience what happened i got
hit in the head with a kilo of coke
that's all i could [__] think of you
know i got hit in the head with a kilo
of coke and now my [__] left eye goes
this way
so oh my god
so now they're gonna send they sent me
[__] guys three emails of exercises i
got to do i just finished the first
batch this morning not jumping jacks or
sit-ups i gotta breathe into a bag for
90 minutes a day 90 seconds a day five
times a day i gotta get a [__] stick
and do all this [__] and then they're
gonna do all this stuff now i gotta go
back next friday
and if i don't do the exercise if she
doesn't see that it's improved a little
bit she can't do nothing with me she's
gonna send me [__] really really
really detailed professional help the
good thing was i don't have any
concussions nothing like that there's
nothing going on no beginnings of
dementia the bad thing is i gotta fix
this left eye
because that's what happens when i drive
it's [__] hilarious
that when you drive you focus
and then
she was telling me she goes your two
eyes start that way but it's like subaru
headlights anybody have subaru or subaru
the headlights go where they adjust so
let's say you're going down a [__]
cave and there's something over here the
headlight will switch on subaru i don't
know if you i forget what it's called
i'm very sorry go to subaru.com and get
the [__] details i don't know
but you're sitting there and and you
look up this way and the lights will
change so i think that's what that's
what she said happens to my eye
that after a while of focusing
if i'd hit too many turns or something
like that she goes you're not getting
cars sick your eyes are making your
brain and your ears all [__] up so
sorry guys i just left
oh i need i need
three [__] different pair glasses
i can't get the she already contacted
the [__] people at not costco
somewhere else walmart
i don't know she goes that's some of the
best place to get glasses
they hit me with regular glasses reading
glasses driving glasses and nighttime
glasses
because of the left [__] eye and
they're thinking they give me one of
those darker shades you like when you
ever see those dudes that come up with
the clear on the right and they got a
little clear a little darker on the left
guys all you could do is [__] laugh
about this [__] this is what happens
when you get old but this is what i'm
talking about guys i always knew there
was going to be a problem with cocaine
there's no way
you're gonna get hit there with two
kilos of coke and [__] bounce around
your life without no you know i look at
ozzy osbourne he's a prime example i
look at ozzy these guys were deep
cocaine heads so i look at ozzy and i
see what faults he's had and he's had
millions of [__] dollars so he could
get everything he's got wrong with him
fixed you know
but i was always concerned about this
[__] and here we go the [__] eye
dye was the first victim
of the coke blizzard of ours of 19
[__] 80 with uncle joey
and it happens guys but it's just so
weird how
thinking back to this like i don't
i'm so happy that
yeah i'm sure i get a little [__]
backlash
from the drugs from here to there i have
bad days
lately i've been finding myself saying
[__] that i don't want to say
like you would like say something you're
like where did that come from so i'm
getting like that pete rose type thing
like pete rose you know [__] says
some crazy [__]
yeah but at least i know i know and i
could take care of it and at least i
could [__] get some help for it or
whatever the [__] it is i mean i'm not
saying crazy [__] but i do i'm a little
louder than i was before
i say some crazier [__] in marlborough
which these are nice white people they
don't deserve me [__] saying
craziness around them
manalapan all these people are very
[__] nice down here but
i'll tell you man the people that i have
in my life that are on drugs it's been
very interesting because
i couldn't figure out what's going on
like with our friendship like i'm like
what the [__] is going on
and all of a sudden to be honest i got
this [__] disturbing
text here that just disturbing from a
dear friend of mine
you know
they try to tell you they're not getting
high
but they're getting [__] high
and
it's really delusional we haven't spoken
in a while
so he reached out just to tell me that
you know he uh
he's doing better or whatever
but in the whole thing i knew he had to
throw something at me and i've known
this dude for a long time
he threw something at me like from high
school
oh my god damn it
like you did something to me and this is
the second time he's mentioned in the
year
you know i sent him some money on paypal
and uh
it's just
i feel bad i i just hope that
i can still to i know he's getting right
and i know you're going joe why'd you
send the money listen he's my age
he's struggling
i'm not enabling him i'm just i i don't
know you know it's just but
guys i'm just really happy i don't do
coke and it's so weird right now
if you're getting high and anything
listen i'm not here to [__] uh
tell you not to get high because nobody
was gonna tell me when i was 40 enough
to get high
nobody was going to tell me that i was
sturdy not to get high and i'll tell you
what if you told me when i was 20 enough
to get out i'd probably [__] hit you
with the car or something like that i'm
not going to lie to you you know but
guys think about it for your uncle joey
man
those drugs are [__] up and
it took me all this time to say it
whether it's cocaine
the [__] pills the [__] uh you
know the pain pills all that [__] it
affects you
it [__] affects you man
there's no way i did everything the last
15 years
that i couldn't do for 44 [__] years
you know what
it's august september we're three months
away from me and 15 years not doing coke
and i could write um
it'll take me three pages to write the
good things i did since in the last 15
years
in the first before all those years of
being coked up i don't remember 15
things i did that were good i remember
10 things i did i was good the only
thing i remember is
maybe getting on stage
when i came out of that cocaine i told
you guys that i couldn't get on stage
for a [__] year
you know a year and a half well that's
probably what it was
you know it was that it just puts a
damper on your life man and i'm here to
tell you i mean
guys i had a great time
i [__] had a great time doing drugs
if you come to me again and go i'm going
to make you 20 again would you do the
drugs i say yeah till 30.
let's cut it by 10 years let's just do
drugs while i was 30. and then you could
smoke pot or have your little cocktails
or whatever the [__] you do to make you
feel better but everything else guys and
i see what's going on now like listen
when i was 20 and 25 and 30
i'm not saying i wasn't lurking in
danger
you could do a line of coke and die
it's happened
you know you could do a listen you get
in a [__] car and hit somebody with
the car after you drink it's happened
you know
but
i sit here now and i'm like i did so
many [__] things in 15 years without
the coke and guys it hasn't been a a
smooth journey
we had those edibles you know we had
[__] reefer it was you know we've
discussed it last
wednesday on the podcast lee and i it
was it was non-stop
you know cat tranquilizes which he
reminded me of
happy pills from vegas that he reminded
me of
it was uh
and we were making the [__] happen
we were making it happen but we weren't
conscious for the experience
and that's [__] not good
that's not good
we were not conscious for the experience
you know
yeah and i was at uncle vinnie's we were
all talking about
people who stick with comedy you know
and they uh
have like a [__] like it's not good
you know at the end it's never [__]
good you know
and i made a statement and one of the
comments said to me you made that
statement it just wasn't and he was
right he goes i said that if you're 45
years old and you're still a feature act
you should start considering something
else
and he was like i don't agree with that
or you wouldn't but that's what i did
that's what i did
at 45 i had
nothing going on nothing so what was 45
45 was uh
40 would have been
so 45 was 2008
right
i got married in 2000 [__] nine
right off the [__] powder after i was
sober a year
i didn't make any decisions till i was
that's how cautious i was i was very
cautious i took my time
i didn't go to meetings but i read the
big book you know i read an addiction
book from time to time i didn't i knew i
didn't want to go back it took me six
months to not be scared anymore
of getting high like it took me six
months to go woof
okay i don't think about it every day
now let's get six months and that was
six months of sleep you know you you go
to bed you wake up and your mind gets
better little by little by little you
just get better and better and better it
took me a year to start making
decisions and that's that's the decision
when i got married
and at the wedding i was like i don't
want to [__] do stand up no more like
i i love doing it with joe
i'll go on the road with joe and i'll
[__] uh
i was gonna get a job selling cars at
the fourth place around my house and
i would have done anything i would
audition because i was in l.a anyway i'm
gonna audition but i quit [__] comedy
i was pretty much done i was like yeah
open for joe if he wants me to
and then one day i got a call from
felicia we started doing podcasting and
the podcasting led to other things and
here we are but i wouldn't have released
that statement
if i didn't live it you know when i was
45 i didn't see it i didn't see myself
yeah i had some movies under my belt and
i was a regular at the comedy store but
i didn't see that this was going to turn
into anything special
and then through podcasting it came back
and
i became the comic that i am today but
it's it's it's very weird that
you have to really look at yourself when
you're growing in this type of art thing
because
at 45 you're still a comic and you're
still trying to hustle
and you're still a feature acting trying
to hustle [__] spots i don't know
what's going on with your home life
but if you're a feature act you probably
got no [__] you know you're out there
every week
so you may have a girlfriend you may not
have a girlfriend so it depends on what
point of your life you are but there's
got to be a point in your life where you
look inside and say
this is either working
or it's not working you have to be very
honest with yourself
when i decided to get out of comedy it
wasn't that
it worked
it [__] worked i was at the store i
told you i already had great movies
under my belt i had some great things i
had done but i was ready to move on i
didn't know
that the podcasting would help open up
another chapter and i'm happy it did but
guys so much has happened i said i
didn't get high anymore so if you're
getting high whatever don't quit today
quit on your [__] time
but know that there's going to be a
greener [__] pastor out there just
know i i i'm telling you this right now
whether you're taking one pill a night a
couple pain pills you're snorting coke
you're drinking
if you [__] take it just take a time
off there's a green pastor over there
and it's [__] waiting for you how do
i know because it was waiting for me i
never thought i could ever get off a
[__] drug so weird i was reading this
uh
article the other day by uh
my friend what's her name tiffany
haddish
and she was talking about it was an
article she did in some women's magazine
and i was talking about what she did
with the money from uh girls trip she
got 80 grand and she paid off a house
and people were like what the [__] are
you doing
and she goes i want to pay it off and
then something else happened
and she bought a house and she started
questioning
about generational wealth
so she started and this is what people
you know when you look at tiffany addis
you don't think about this [__]
but it all came down to
tiffany had his pain off that house
because she never wanted to be homeless
again
she never wanted to be homeless you know
it's so
it's so funny how your mind just grips
on to certain things you know i took
such a beating in my first marriage i
was such a loser let's get it right i
was such a loser
in my first marriage that for years i
didn't want to look at it that i had
lost i thought marriage was just [__]
bad
you know
uh
so i was turned off to the idea that's
why when i did that thing with ryan
sickler i spoke about that that i was
just dating women for a long time and it
was getting me nowhere and it was time
to [__] latch on to something like
that i don't even know where i'm going
with this but
what she was trying to say tiffany had
issues what i do with my life you know
i got locked up and
actually got locked up another 10 times
you know in my life but
i learned so much from getting locked up
that i knew one thing i never wanted to
go there again i never wanted to go
there again
like there was no way i was going there
again and i yeah i did some slip ups and
stuff but enough nothing up in prison
and i ended up on a [__] stage you
know
you know
i don't want to be homeless i don't want
to be on drugs again i mean
and it's so weird when you get off drugs
you always feel like you could relapse
at any time so i'm a little cautious
about that but i'm not i was oh [__]
mike
mike and i were talking about movies the
other day and uh
we were talking about the crow
mike loves the crow i [__] love the
crow
i love the crow so much that i broke out
in psd on that when i was watching it
it was on it was on from the beginning i
sat mercy down and we watched a [__]
crow and
you know all those guys
i forgot that i had met the guy that was
a pawn shop owner
i did a movie with his ex-lover before
he
died guy's very very gay
very nice guy and i i'm when i met his
gay lover and he told me he was married
to him
i said ask him dog do you know he did
miami vice and he's like no i didn't
because he was a young guy
gideon
gideon in the movie and he goes no i
didn't
i go ask him tonight when he played
elgato
he used to wear a cape and [__] that's
when i knew he was gay when he wore the
cape and he wore like little glasses
and he played elgato and he came back
the guy next thing goes oh my god i
talked to my husband
he said that was the time of his life
that he was just banging
18 year old studs in miami and all this
[__]
but uh
i love that movie to crow for reasons
that nobody would understand you know
it's just bruce lee's sending a message
to the world like that for me when i was
watching it dark and [__]
it might
drugged up disgusted cuban mind i'm like
this is bruce lee sending a message with
his son whatever but it didn't matter
there's a scene in that movie where the
[__] guy who [__] his japanese
sister
is snorting coat
and i'll never forget that he's having a
conversation
he's gibberish and he [__] puts a
straw down
he does a line of coke and i looked at
that
and i'm like right now people would
think that i would get my car and run
and
buy coke like that that would make you
you know
that could be a trigger for some people
i'm like
bro that's a trigger for me to stay off
the [__]
like the opposite like i'm when i see
that [__] now it's like wow and guys
again i [__] love cocaine i used to
put it on my dick
i would stick it in my [__] from time
when i found out you could put a coke
rock in your ass no i didn't do that yes
i [__] did no wonder i [__] crooked
the shaft is all off of my [__]
you think i'm [__] kidding yeah never
mind the eyeball cocaine [__] ruined
me
and that's it for a [__] monday
morning [__]
that's all you need today we already
[__] your world up i had a great week
last week and it's going to be a good
week this week we're doing wednesday and
then uh hopefully we could do monday but
next week i'm out of town for uh eight
days and then we come back
for labor day and after labor day it's
[__]
full [__] steam ahead straight to
2000 and [__] 23.
uh this is the time of the year you know
one of my sponsors this week is liquid
iv
and the other sponsor is uh draftkings
who i [__] love to debt they're great
i'm gonna tell you something this is the
time of the year to get on with
draftkings don't i know it's the ufc
this week
usman you're gonna have a great time
watching great fights on that card but
this is the time of the year
where it's pro football [__] i
couldn't believe i turned on the tv this
week and i was football i'm like what
the [__]
and they didn't have one game on
yesterday i had like 20 games on when i
was on that party saturday night i was
sitting there at a table at this
restaurant in the back room
and i kept watching the pittsburgh game
like i can't find anyone kept switching
it to denver dallas and i'm like holy
[__] what the and i looked at the
[__] phone it's
the 14th the 13th of the [__] august
so but
i just want to say one thing today
because i was taught talking on tiffany
haddish on how you uh
when she said she didn't want to be
homeless again and that's what she took
out of being homeless that's why she
bought a
house today is the 36th anniversary of
me getting sentenced to prison
so
i want to send this
i want to send a shout out to myself
for making it happen and
the judge for throwing me in [__]
jail
the cop and my man ken bella for taking
the kidnapping like a man that he is in
fact i'm gonna call him tonight out of
respect i might even take the
conversation for you [__]
just so you could hear me congratulate
them to make it
from that ropey afternoon that we had
them all tied up in the rope and [__]
and uh
but now that's it and that's that today
was 36 [__] days i spoke to my
brother yesterday georgie and i go
georgie think about it today you were on
your way to colorado taking a flight
there 36 [__] years ago
that's a long [__] time ago but guess
what [__]
that burns in my [__] heart every day
and every time i think about that
anniversary my dick gets hard i did it i
didn't cop out
i didn't run away i didn't go to another
country i did my time i [__] got out
there
and uh i became what i became whether
it's good or bad i'm still here slinging
dick i love you [__] with all
my heart
stay black and i'll see you [__]
wednesday
and now for a word from my [__]
sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] uncle
joey here again thank you for listening
on this beautiful
monday morning like i said the joint is
brought to you by draftkings the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc this weekend we got ufc 278 it's
usman against edwards rematch i don't
have any picks yet i wait for the
breakdowns i owe the weigh-ins i look to
see how they react if they're holding
water what the [__] is really going on
if they're scared but don't worry about
that this saturday new customers can bet
five dollars and get 200 and free bets
instantly
win or lose and if that's not enough
action draftkings has a 10 risk-free
same game paul a combined multiple bets
like which fighter will come up on top
and how long the fight will last
and you can win extra dough more legs
means more money i love these cards this
week like i said i don't have nothing
for you yet i got to see the weigh-ins
but draftkings is safe secure and
reliable withdraw your cash whenever the
hell you want what i'm going to do this
is do me a favor download the draftking
sportbook app right now use promo code
joey j-o-e-y
bet 5 dollars on ufc 278 and get 203
bets instantly and listen it's football
season also next week that's code joey
this saturday at draftking sportsbook
the official sports betting partner the
ufc and here's what the lawyers make me
say minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply
see my show notes for details all right
beside that just download download the
draftking sportsbook app and let's make
some [__] money and if you really
want to make some money and test your
football knowledge
download the draftkings fantasy app oh
[__] and they got mma on that dude
let's do it [__] the joint is
also brought to you by
liquid iv listen when it comes to heat
and you [__] staying hydrated liquid
iv that's their [__] priority
making hydration a priority makes us
feel healthier and every in our everyday
lives all right liquid iv is tremendous
it comes in tremendous flavors concord
grape is one of my favorites i like the
tropical punch the lemon lime ain't bad
the kombucha is tremendous use liquid iv
like uncle joey first thing in the
morning before the day starts when
you're feeling run down or maybe you had
a long night out you got yates that
[__] monkey to death
and uh now you [__] uh run down and
you you're looking for something to
quench your thirst that's where liquid
iv comes in with five essential vitamins
b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c it contains
three times the electrolytes how many of
those drinks you buy at 7-eleven or
whatever the [__] you drink made with
premium ingredients liquid iv is free
from gluten dairy and soy and they also
use cellular transport technology
designed to enhance rapid absorption of
water and other key ingredients into
your bloodstream so do me a favor grab
your liquid iv in bulk at costco or i'm
going to save you 15 percent when you
shop direct at liquidity.com 15 off at
liquidity.com when you use promo code
joey at checkout that's 15 off anything
you order when you shop at liquid iv.com
i want to thank liquid iv i want to
thank draftkings i want to thank you
savages for making it happen i'll be
back wednesday morning tip top magoo
[__] stay black uncle joey got
your back
you